if the democrats were to get behind
someone like a mark cuban uh that would
be the best approach to defeat
trump because you have someone who's a
mavericky no pun intended mavericky
billionaire businessman
who is a capital i independent
he's not a creature of the establishment
he's not like these i think if you run
anyone who smacks of washington dc
or capital d democrat you lose one of my
beliefs is that
uh americans have just been casting
about for change over and over again
like obama was changed
bernie was changed trump was changed
joe strangely enough was changed from
trump because people were like okay like
i'm a little bit tired of
of this
stick during the pandemic
um and then now people in my opinion are
getting tired of joe and then if if you
run
uh
amy or pete or kamala that they're gonna
be the establishment and they're they're
gonna have a tough they're probably
gonna lose to trump um so you need to go
outside of the establishment and get
someone um i think cuban would make
sense i think if you were to go really
far out like you and get
even like a well-loved celebrity figure
um
like
uh an oprah or the rock or
you know like one of these types
um you know i i think it would steal a
lot of the thunder from trump you know
i mean there are a lot of people that
just again they want to change they want
someone independent of the machine they
want someone who can hold their
attention
in a positive way
you know and not and not just say
political pablum that's [ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
this week on forward
2024 is it gonna be biden trump are
there better choices among the democrats
we actually think about who the
democrats could and should field
in the next presidential race also the
terrible michigan shooting
chris cuomo getting fired by cnn
elizabeth holmes and more this week on
forward
[Music]
and we are back on the forward podcast
uh why are zach and i not in the same
place
if you're watching this video it's
because i am at an ai conference
in uh the caribbean i know it's a bit of
a boondoggle but here i
am the dream man
you're living the dream you just posted
evelyn just posted a picture of you on
instagram uh covered in monkeys what are
those those are lemurs they are
delightful they have thumbs
um their
fingers feel like little tiny leather
suction cups
that's weird i highly recommend feeding
lemurs if you ever have an occasion to
do so
yeah actually in college we had a lemur
center on campus i gotta go uh
it made me ask them why have we not
domesticated these animals because
they're so adorable and gentle and
friendly and the answer was that the
lemur will just run away and we can
you'll never see it again
that's
that's apparently why lemurs are you
know not good pets
uh learning a lot about the future of ai
meeting some great people uh you know
obviously sharing some some words of
wisdom too
but i want to start off talking about
this cover story in the atlantic which
is very much
uh been on my mind and it's not the
first time it's been raised it was
raised by bill maher it was raised by
robert kagan in the washington post but
the theme is that
there is a
trump
plan
to
essentially
win regardless of the vote count
uh in 2024
um as a follow-up to the undermining
of the
election in 2020 and there's this
massive the big lie stop the steel the
election was stolen
a line of argument that
is believed by tens of millions of
americans and i guess you know i don't
think it i'd need to say this but i
obviously don't think that stuff's legit
like i think that
uh trump lost the election um yeah uh
according to to
every shred of information that i've
seen
[Laughter]
the courts have seen too but yeah the
courts i mean a lot of stuff was
spurious and thrown out um this atlantic
article is worth reading and i think
this has to be front and center because
i'm getting very very frustrated by the
fact that there's this impending
disaster coming down the pike and
everyone's like oh we can't do anything
about it so we're going to talk about
what the heck
can be done
to preserve democracy in the face of
trump running
in 2024. now a few things i want to
stipulate really quickly and some some
of this we've said before yes i think
trump's going to run yes i think he's
going to win the nomination
he's going to be in great position maybe
to just to win straight up
and so first let's try and review
his opponent who the heck is going to
represent the democrats in 2024
now
the obvious choice is joe biden the
incumbent who defeated trump once the
major drawbacks are that he will be
nearly 82 years old he'll be 82 in
november of 2024 so he's he'll be like
81.9
uh when uh when election day is coming
around
uh and his numbers right now are not
great i mean a lot can change obviously
but right now he's at 42 or so
um
81 is pretty old 81.9 i mean that's a
thing and this is a tough job it ages
you quick
um so
next up would be kamala harris but
kamala la the last number said that she
pulled six points worse than joe
um and so here's my my major push
is that the democrats need to figure out
who the [ __ ] is running in 2024
and get behind that person
now
you know
i mean maybe you don't need to spill the
beans with the rest of us
like maybe you don't want to like come
out yeah
so the the tough thing here is that joe
does not want to be a lame duck he
doesn't want everyone just to be like
okay you're like you're one and done so
he wants to pretend like he's running
again
in 2024. i think he genuinely wants to
run again in 2024
but i i think that you know that like
the man is old
and and he's going to be
like the
visible
avatar of a fading establishment you
know what i mean like he was old this
time
um and
you know i've been around joe any number
of times uh you know over
uh the
um the months when we were on the trail
i i would literally speak before and
after him
um in new hampshire and iowa where how
many times were you around joe
with me zach like how many times
yeah a good amount um
my favorite show by moment dude was
before the
miami debate
was our first debate so we're nervous as
hell we all line up in the hallway and
joe was like late and he came in was
like i say this like i didn't think he
was going to win that's the thing but he
was so damn smooth walking into that
line he would like look like a silver
fox cool as a cucumber like a dad at a
barbecue just like shaking everybody's
hand give him a big smile big grin is
like damn dude that's politician like i
don't explain like he was just cool calm
collected um
i'll never forget that ever um but he
was like great to you and you guys got
to know each other pretty well or you
know at least friendly-wise yeah and i
saw him campaign when he was you know
fairly robust and doing well i saw him
on other occasions where he was not
great
um and
he did do poorly in both iowa and new
hampshire and part i think because they
saw a fair amount of him and and day to
day joe was not
killing it on the campaign trail yeah my
moment was like one small backstage
moment like day to day he feels older
you know
yeah now i mean i i like
you're right that there were uh periods
too when he was very winning like i
always got along great with joe i liked
joe
um on that level
um but when i've seen him on tv
lately
um even i can pick up a difference
between him now and him
uh
17 months ago or whatever the heck it is
you know what i mean yeah like when
we're like like that there there is
something happening
um and again this job ages you quick
now so joe does not want to talk about
him not running again because it makes
him less relevant and into a lame duck
um
and no one wants to talk about the fact
that kamala may not be
the pick
um but you can tell that there's a ton
of
uh anxiety
around kamala as the
as the next
standard bearer for the democratic party
because of all these negative press
stories that are coming out
someone in the biden administration
certainly in on
oh yeah these are leads these are
planted stories yeah they're trying to
either blame her for mistakes of the
administration which happens all the
time in you know president vice
president relationships or
beat her up enough so that when they
open that they can open up the primary
so so this is my concern zach is that
the democrats don't really reckon with
what the heck's going on um 2022 rolls
around uh democrats get wiped out by the
republicans in the fall in terms of the
house maybe the senate but almost
certainly the house
you know that there's a poll that falls
on the democrats in dc everyone's like
oh no
23 rolls around
trump declares
the democrats still haven't figured out
who's running and then they essentially
default to joe because they're like well
but then then joe runs
um and
just loses straight up to trump i see
this as the most likely scenario um
right now
uh now there the next thing up would be
that joe i mean he literally could have
a health problem
um and then kamala could become the
acting president or
the you know
and then be running as essentially the
incumbent um so then you have that
dynamic too
where it's trump versus kamala
i think that kamal has a much better
chance if she's the incumbent than if
she's not
um but
at this point i i can almost see in my
mind's eye like that there being this
collective freak out in the democratic
party trying to figure out who's going
to
run
uh and then i don't think kamala clears
the field and then you do have a
competitive primary and you and i are
now going to talk a little bit about
what the heck that field looks like
um so
this this is frustrating to me because i
i think that there's
still
no real
sense as to who the democratic standard
bear is going to be and if they're in
figured out mode in 23 maybe that's fine
in the sense that you know like like
maybe you need for lightning to strike
um but one thing that i do know is that
most of the democrats with national
aspirations
ran in 2020 like there there was it was
a wide open field there were 24
candidates like if you were someone who
thought hey like you know i might want
to be president
you probably ran
um and so let's talk about the folks who
would likely run in a 2023 democratic
primary starting with the most obvious
challenger to kamala be pete bootaj he's
probably the top draft pick i guess for
the dems yeah so so pete has a lot of
strengths a lot of assets he's very
smart
very good campaigner really excellent
with the media the media just seems to
love pete and you understand it um he's
uh an extraordinarily high level media
athlete
he's super articulate his depth of
knowledge and policy very very good yeah
his major
deficiency in terms of electoral
democratic politics is that he's had a
hard time connecting with voters of
color
where if you look at
his performance during the primaries and
it'd be funny if there was a primary
again we'd be going to very well trodden
ground in the sense that it would be in
new hampshire and you know pete still
has friends in a lot of these places
um so pete performed very well in iowa
new hampshire and then when he got to
nevada and south carolina um the just
the the bottom went out you know like
his support evaporated
in large part because those
constituencies were more diverse
and pete has a very very strong and
clear appeal
to
conventional mainstream democrats who
uh
you know who are white
really
um yeah but uh
so
would it change over the this
number of months that pete would develop
that connection with voters of color who
knows
uh you know his other potential drawback
might might be that he's a bit on the
younger side i think he's 39 right now
he has been secretary of transportation
for
um you know
several years but that's not what people
think of really as
training to be president like i think
most americans would struggle to name
um any previous secretary of
transportation
like it's it's not really thought of as
that kind of
um succession
type
um
type type pick
um but but pete has
very high name id at least among dems
and so i think pete is your is your
strongest choice in part and one of the
reasons why i want to talk about this is
that i think that democrats need to be
building up somebody
um and pete at least has been through a
race and so has some of that name id um
and whatnot
uh another person that was in that race
that you can see
uh running again is amy klobuchar what
do you think about amy i think she she
hits the same lane as pete does in many
ways in that uh
midwestern
uh
they're not actually
like authentic or that relatable but
they're more authentic and relatable
compared to i think a lot of other
politicians uh they come off as folksy
and
um
i think
i i think if it's amy klobuchar the
badass um
she's uh a very a pretty compelling
candidate i think um at least if you're
just talking about like a
institutionally backed democratic
contender what do you think the one of
the reasons why i'm animated about this
is i i think that it would be tough to
pick any of these candidates against
trump
in 24. oh yeah
and and so that's the thing that i want
to try and really
grapple with is that
that if you're the democrats i mean the
fact is democrats lost to trump once in
part because you had hillary as the
nominee um i i think and the fix was in
for hillary and i think if that had been
bernie then you know there's a chance
that it goes the other direction even
though bernie wasn't quarter court
electable and hillary was quote unquote
electable
and then your electable candidate loses
to trump and so you know you screwed
that up once
um
and
you you're on the verge this is my big
thing it's like you're on the verge of
screwing it up again
um because you're going to run someone
who's going to to lose to trump
uh and and we can all see this coming by
the way again you know three years
beforehand and i'm kind of beseeching uh
to the extent that there's you know any
any chance of getting through to
democrats it's like you might want to
get ahead of this freight train because
there are front page articles kind of
painting the picture and you're like
looking at it then we're going to talk
about other things you could do to maybe
prevent this catastrophe
uh so
uh i i
you know i i think that this field
um it's going to be tough for any of
them to beat trump
um and so one of the things that i'm
going to suggest first let me address
too it's like uh someone said look if
the democrats have a primary some new
people show up too which is probably
true
some people
likely saw me or tom steyer run last
time and then then they show up so you
know you don't know precisely who this
field looks like there might be some new
actor heck you know i mean i could show
up again i'm not you know like yeah
bernie's an independent and he ran i
mean i could be like hey like i'm not
i'm in a bed and i'm running anyways
you know i would would i do that
probably not but
but would there be someone who
resembles that who shows up like is
there a bit of uh you know
um
a process
um yes
um but i i think that
we the the democrats that they wanted
someone to beat trump would need someone
who embodies some of the
anti-institutionalist fervor
that trump
embodies right um and none of the people
we named actually have that energy or
vibe like they all feel very very
um establishment e
of the major
democratic contenders the one who
doesn't feel establishment at all is
bernie
um because bernie's just you know like
uh
socialists do to the people who wants to
you know um
redistribute things and like give things
to poor people and you know it's like
like so people like okay he's not
corrupt uh or
captive in in the same way that they
feel a lot of politicians are
um so i feel like
what democrats should be doing is trying
to just have one
qualification which is does this person
beat trump not do i wish this person uh
you know be trump but like i actually
would defeat him um and so i think
democrats would be well served to go
outside of their conventional candidates
and find someone who actually has a bit
of that
energy
[Music]
this episode of the forward podcast is
brought to you by better help is there
anything preventing you from achieving
your goals or interfering with your
happiness
betterhelp.com
yang is a fantastic way
to get your head on straight in my
opinion uh betterhelp can assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist so
connect in a safe and private
environment online it's so convenient
i've been using it probably for the past
eight months you can start communicating
under 48 hours it's not a crisis line
it's not particularly self-help it's
just professional counseling done
securely online you can communicate with
your counselor anytime whether that's
text or email or video
phone it's pretty awesome convenient and
it's available worldwide so whether
you're looking to help you with
depression or stress or anxiety
relationships or sleeping or family
conflicts for me it's about
just letting off some steam and talking
about the real things that happen in
life and now let's all be real since
covid we've all been going through it so
i want you guys to check out better help
and start living a happier life today so
as a listener to forward podcast you'll
get 10 off your first month by visiting
our sponsor at betterhelp.com yang so
join over one million people who have
taken charge their mental health again
that's better help help dot com slash
yang
[Music]
one of the reasons i don't love
kamala pete
joe still a little bit um
klobuchar is because they are
team dem democrats in a sense and
they're institutionalized and trump eats
politicians for breakfast actually
breakfast lunch and dinner and it's too
easy of a lane for him because he just
could say everything's bad because of
these people he just gets a point finger
the whole time and he's been that
forever it's authentic people identify
with it hill hammer at home
when here's my question for you so in
2016 before you ran
um
in my mind's eye i was like how do you
beat trump and my two ideas were either
the whole party lines up behind like the
plain vanilla candidate which we ended
up doing it was joe
but some were like all right this guy's
like passable it doesn't matter just get
trump out
or
hey i thought it had to be a young
anonymous um
i thought had to be a male to kind of
combat his masculine energy but like an
unknown coming out of nowhere and maybe
combating with a certain type of of new
politics and and pete was that and you
were that you both kind of checked that
box um
but
i'm trying to look at 2024 and i'm
curious your thoughts on if you let's
blank slate it and i know it's not
really fair but theoretically how do you
defeat him
what is this round three i guess this is
round three if trump running for
president right
yeah so i i i think that if the
democrats were to get behind someone
like a mark cuban uh that would be the
best approach to defeat
trump because you have someone who's a
mavericky no pun intended mavericky
billionaire businessman
uh who is a capital i independent
he's not a creature of the establishment
he's not like these i think if you run
anyone who smacks of washington dc
or capital d democrat you lose
like you need to go outside of your own
backyard or in crowd
and get someone who actually can make a
similar case to trump and say okay
things suck it's a mess
we need real change and i represent real
change one of my
beliefs is that
uh americans have just been casting
about for change over and over again
like obama was changed
bernie was changed trump was changed
joe strangely enough was changed from
trump because people were like okay like
i'm a little bit tired of
above this stick during the pandemic
um and then now people in my opinion are
getting tired of joe and then if if you
run
uh
amy or pete or kamala they're gonna be
the establishment and they're they're
gonna have a tough they're probably
gonna lose to trump um so you need to go
outside of the establishment and get
someone um i think cuban would make
sense
i think if you were to go really far out
like you and get
even like a well-loved celebrity figure
um like
uh an oprah or the rock or let you know
like one of these types
um you know i i think it would steal a
lot of the thunder from trump you know
i mean there are a lot of people that
just again they want to change they want
someone independent of the machine they
want someone who can hold their
attention
in a positive way
uh you know and not and not just say
political pablum that's [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um so
so that this is
oh the the thing i want to emphasize is
like look
we can see that disaster is coming down
the pike uh in 24.
um and so you should be thinking
about trying to avert disaster and not
just kind of trundle along do the thing
that comes naturally and oh by the way
you're gonna lose and then you know
extra x months later we're looking up
being like okay what that will happen so
number one is trying to actually win
fair and square along with the votes
and then number two would be to try and
make sure that the vote count matters um
because
they're going to be trying to undermine
and subvert election findings
um
the whole time
um there are tens of millions of
americans that now are on board with
that general narrative and just refuse
to believe that trump loses unless it's
stolen from him
um
and i i said something to someone that i
believe and it's going to be tough if
trump runs i have a hard time imagining
a scenario where we don't have some type
of
um widespread political violence uh and
unrest in 24
because if trump
wins straight up which again i see as
right now
uh probably the most likely scenario um
with some of the opponents that we we've
described right then there are protests
around the country because trump won
again and you know you'd have
um
uh
people in blue states and in urban areas
and other other places um protesting
you'd probably have people show up in dc
protesting
um certainly you know after trump
resumed living in the white house
um but i think there'd be protests
immediately
and if trump
loses and claims victory then you'd have
political violence uh
from the other direction where you'd
have tons of
mega folks out in the street saying the
election was stolen again
um i think that those people will be
spoiling for a fight particularly after
trump spends months ginning them up
um
if he's running
so you are looking at uh really really
bleak tempestuous tough
uh season
and so one of the questions is how can
you try and strengthen
people's sense of resolve around
the vote and voting and other things
um now this is some of the work that i'm
doing with the forward party
which is i think in 22
there is a chance that you can shift
certain environments from party
primaries to
open primaries
that could change in the incentives for
critical mass of republican legislators
who could then
look up and maybe
pass
legislation saying you can't
fire secretaries of state or you know
you can't like for no reason or you
can't just have state legislators
uh decide
who the electoral votes go to uh you
know that's not the point of
of the state legislators certifying is
not just a you know counteract the will
of the people
um so we have uh uh an opportunity in
2022 that everyone should be staring at
um and
a lot of the action is around
um moderate republicans who don't like
trump but feel like if they say a bad
word about him then their career is
going to be over or worse yet that their
families are going to be threatened did
you read the article in the atlantic
about peter meyer and his
experience
so i i thought this was very very
compelling there were 10 members of
congress who voted to impeach donald
trump right um and originally it was
looking like 20 and then it just went
down and down and down because all of
them were being threatened um and so
this is an article by our friend tim
alberta in the atlantic about peter
meyer who by the way is only 33 years
old had just taken his seat
just shows up and then is getting asked
to vote whether to impeach trump and
then he's getting text messages from
everyone being like don't do it don't do
it don't do it and then he kind of
stared long and hard in the mirror and
was like i think i have to do it
and uh and then he
ended up having his um
you know like his safety threatened and
like all this stuff and and all these
members of congress and so there's
there's this thing where apparently a
bunch of people were in the same
situation but they a lot of them just
decided out of fear for their own
physical safety to just be like i'm not
going to vote
impeach trump
um
and and that to me
it's a very very worthwhile read uh this
tim alberta piece about peter meyer and
i i met peter meyer
i've actually known him socially for a
while because i did work in detroit and
he's been
you know working hard on economic
development um for a long time so i like
peter
i find him to be very reasonable and
principled so he did the right thing in
in this direction and
paid a massive price
but interestingly peter seems like he's
going to
um actually get reelected
for a variety of reasons but of the
members of congress who voted to impeach
trump of those ten two have already said
they're not running again anthony
gonzalez in ohio and then adam kinzinger
in illinois
um
which is a huge loss so you have a very
very small number of republicans who
decided to
uh stand up to trump and it hasn't gone
well for them i mean that's the main
thing in this article is that the people
who decided to stand up for principle
were not shielded or rewarded
[Music]
have you thought about certain friends
and family members and what you're going
to get them for the holidays this year
well we have a gift idea for you and
that's hello tushy bidets because they
are eco-friendly they're a little techy
and they're actually affordable and
super unique it ticks all the boxes so
you can get tushy bidets as a great gift
for your eco-conscious cousin your neat
freak sister your whoever you want and
your family that might find this awesome
funny or eco-friendly it cuts your
toilet paper use down by 80 percent
and they're pretty awesome so look they
wash your bum with fresh water
and a better way to clean than toilet
paper it's simple spray and pat dry it
attaches your existing toilet so no
plumber electrician needed super easy
you can get it done like less than eight
minutes pretty awesome and it cuts down
your toilet paper use and budget by
eighty percent so saving money and
saving preventative waste or preventing
yourself from excess waste so join
millions of hello tushy happy customers
right now who take care of their you
this is the quote they take care of
their yule logs the dignified way that's
ridiculous but still hilarious so here's
the deal give the gift of a clean bum to
yourself or your loved ones this holiday
season and get 10 off plus free shipping
right now at hellotushi.com
yang
that's hellotushy.com
yang for 10 off and free shipping do it
right now
[Music]
one of the biggest challenges if you
start throwing out names and celebrities
is that they actually have to be media
trained and i don't mean media training
like they took a couple courses like
they have to be a pro at navigating the
media we're talking years of experience
for sure because it's hard and if you
watch
i mean frankly howard schultz i thought
would be a compelling candidate like
guys like from work like work glass
background build starbucks from nothing
like cool story any and your first
interview was like pretty awful um and
not like oh you're a little rusty like
no
dude like you haven't talked to a
regular human in a long time man um
and bloomberg had a bit of that too um
and you can overcome it with money and
things like that but um
cuban is one that's so compelling
because
he is in the public eye all the time off
script you know he's on podcasts he's on
cuban's a media
pro
yeah um and cuban also and like i know
mark cuban can talk to a regular guy and
it's like like totally comfortable you
know
he'll shoot the [ __ ] with anyone right i
mean he owns a [ __ ] you know sports
team you know not to say that all these
sports owners
are are able to do that because a lot of
them can't
but but so that was a bad argument to
use but cuban
is
um you know as a relatable human in
my experience right now it's it's pete
you know it's like i don't know i'm just
uh well right now it's joe or kamala
you know and the the other thing is i so
there there has been some scuttlebutt
and this is very very dc-ish it's very
kind of house of cards-ish i don't know
if you heard this [ __ ] it's actually
west wingish
where where they're saying that they
want to put kamala on the supreme court
as an elegant way of getting her so
everyone knows that
it's going to be very difficult uh in
terms of appearances to
uh have kamala step aside because she's
a woman of color and you can't just
shove the
black woman aside and then insert some
other dude
um and so there has to be a way for her
to exit uh gracefully and so that this
is one of the ideas that's out there so
um you know it's like can you see
something of a reshuffling of the deck
um let me say for the record i think
that this is exactly the kind of thing
you should be thinking about or doing
because just
kind of like walking along and letting
days pass uh and then looking up you
know in 23 and 24 being like hey it
turns out we're not excited about this
plan like that that's that's dumb um so
you know you need to make a clear-eyed
call at some point and say well if we
don't like the way this is going to lay
out then maybe we should be thinking
creatively here talk about future the
nation type stuff because if he wins if
trump just takes the election
uh and if it's close or he didn't
actually win but then takes it uh
i don't know what happens but uh it's
not gonna be good i don't know how you
get them out of there
um because the rules are out the window
if trump wins again which again i will
say it's like i see as the most likely
scenarios we're having this conversation
unfortunately
because i'm no trump fan at all
um
he's going to surround himself with the
most corrupt
sycophants and yes men and women
whereas last time if you remember there
was some cycling through some reasonable
figures or like yeah not so much
this yeah like a bunch of people this
time all of that goes out the window
this time it would be full-on
loyalists
uh and uh really unsavory types you know
it would be like you thought last time
was bad this stuff would get much darker
yeah and then when trump decides to do
something like it would actually maybe
happen
um keep in mind trump also is getting
older he's like he's he's going to be 77
in 2024 um and so i mean just imagine
this unhinged
uh
77 year old who just wants to just you
know settle scores i mean it'd be a
disaster
um so anything we can do to avoid this
uh we should be doing which is why i'm
trying to push hard and be like look if
we just do business as usual
this is
probably what happens and it's it's
going to make last time look like
sanity central
yeah if i'm biden's team right now
it's probably what i do um
i'd have a conversation with joe and at
a certain like figure out sooner rather
than later but say are you going to run
again or not but like do we want to
um
he has the right to run he won the first
time
theoretically he could do it again i
don't think he will at this point but um
and then there's health right
if the answer that is no
then he should at some point
strategically in my opinion resign
which would be
a obviously a massive deal never done
before but let kamala come in
take the present spot and lead for
a year get some experience there but
then you say you now have the right to
do an open primary you say because she
wasn't actually elected we are going to
have a primary and you can run as
incumbent if you want or you can just
finish out the term
to
i to me that is i don't know is the best
thing optically but it's not a bad
choice i don't have your thoughts on
that well i think if you go to joe now
and say are you going to run again he
says yes um
and and this is one of the problems
because you know if your 79 year old
boss is like yeah yeah then they keep
saying yeah yeah and then time passes
big problem we don't want to run yeah
yeah this is an issue i'm going to share
something that i thought was fascinating
i talked to a
woman who runs focus groups on on voters
and she said that
many voters use the phrase bridge
candidate for joe biden let's say you
know he's a bridge like he's you know
one term
and then when they ask uh who's he a
bridge to like who who's who is going to
be president
after joe
uh voters drew a blank
they they did not all just come out and
be like kamala pete they were just like
oh like they were able to kind of
superimpose their
uh fantasy person
after joe
so
i don't hate what you're saying in that
you know you want to actually
have a real
figure
um that joe transitions to if it's not
going to be joe
so him resigning and then kamala
being the incumbent
um at least then people
uh would regard her in that light though
i agree with you she faces a competitive
primary
um in almost any circumstance i think
the only person who avoids the primary
is joe well so the the the other big
part of this is that
um the republican party should be two
parties there there should be a trump
party and then a moderate republican
party the problem right now is the
moderate republicans are all beholden to
the trumpers and their districts and so
they they can't make a principal
decision
um ideally
democrats should be two parties too a
progressive party and then
moderate democrats yeah and then there
would probably be a fifth party
somewhere in the middle uh it's called
the forward party
and then that that would be a functional
system and then the trumpers would
represent about you know let's say half
a democratic party maybe even a little
more but maybe like 30 of the entire
total and then we don't worry about
having
uh
you know autocracy in three years i mean
like that that's an infinitely better
system
um now can you get that done between now
and 24 i mean that that would be the
dream if they just turned around and
actually i i genuinely think that
democrats should be doing this
is check this out this is actually this
is actually the best plan out of
anything we talked about democrats
there's a way you can
preserve democracy no matter what
happens in 2024 and here it is
just pass the fair representation act
which
shifts us from single member districts
to multi-member districts and leads to a
genuinely multi-party system very
quickly because if you have a certain
proportion of votes in a district you
get a representative
and then everything i'm talking about
actually magically happens where uh
trumpers instead of controlling
the republican party they get 25 percent
your moderate republicans with some
other percentage all you need to do is
pass the fair representation act and
democracy survives i'm sure you won't do
it because
um you know like that's not the way you
think but just look it up the fair
representation how does it work
mechanically
so mechanically yeah
but what it does is it makes the us look
a lot like other modern democracies
where
um it's not that the people in a
district get one rep
it's that so let's say that there is a
state um that right now has
you know uh five members of congress
um
and so the the way it would work is and
there are five districts so you know
each district you know
okay this one so what it is you combine
into one super district
and then the representatives get split
up uh based upon the proportion of votes
that each party gets within that super
district so if you had a normal district
you would probably have
one progressive
one moderate dem
one uh one moderate republican
one conservative republican and then the
fifth would be you know
with one of those four
based upon maybe the forward party again
it'd be one of those things so then
every district every super district
would have the same kind of breakup and
so you'd have a congress that looks like
the parliaments of a lot of other
countries where you have you know 20 of
them are progressives and you know like
that this is actually
the best most effective way to preserve
our democracy i don't talk about it that
much because i know there's no chance
that a majority of members of congress
look up tomorrow and say you know what
we should just switch to like genuinely
a representative system and have a multi
but but this is the only way we're going
to save in my opinion um our country
from the this
nightmare scenario in 24. so hey you
know like
fair representation act by 2022 then
problem solved so if i'm a state i have
five seats in my state three are super
red
two are super blue
this would
just be five then depending on how the
popular vote shakes out my state those
five are divided up proportionally
based on performance or who got who
perform well in the election how that
works
well you you'd probably have a similar
makeup like
but it wouldn't be just two parties
probably because um then any anything
like that
and this is the bill on the floor right
now or it's been uh
it's been proposed the firm
representation act sorry i'm so new to
this no no don't worry about it our
friend rokhana i think is one of the
co-sponsors
uh so you know our future democracy uh
our lives i think this bill i think this
bill literally has like let you know
four signings
[Laughter]
but but it but this would be the the
saving grace okay so what are the big
takeaways if you can see a giant
disaster coming down your way a few
years from now you might want to think
big about how you can prevent it and not
just do business as usual so that we all
are left looking up wondering what the
hell happened a few years from now
um so
think bigger
fair representation act recruit someone
who can
give trump some of his own medicine
um but if you just play by your usual
playbook we all suffer for it but we
need to stop pretending everything's
fine as the democratic party that's the
big one yes and if you're a journalist
listening to this also think bigger i
mean come on
amen
[Music]
why are you giving
big tech companies rights and access to
your data
with no consequence it's ridiculous
you've got
frankly
every time you go online there are
companies that are taking your location
browser history you name it and using
that to make money off of you and so to
prevent them from doing that andrew and
i both use expressvpn and it's awesome
you download the expressvpn app you can
get it on your phone get your tablet get
it on your laptop i have on my laptop
you press a button and you have your
very very own virtual private network
where big tech companies nobody can have
access to where you are what data are
you using and hide your ip address that
makes you actively more difficult to
trace and sell to advertiser what's more
expressvpn equips 100 of your network
data to protect you from eavesdroppers
and cyber criminals and what i like most
is how freaking easy it is to you it's
one click it's so easy it was rated
number one by business insider and a
bunch of other places so
let's stop allowing big tech to revoke
our rights to free speech why not revoke
their right to your data instead secure
your internet with vpn that we trust for
online protection visit expressvpn.com
yang that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-v-p-n
dot com slash yang to get three extra
months free with our exclusive link for
the forward podcast listeners go to
expressvpn.com
yang right now
[Music]
i want to get your take on the uh
school shooting in oxford because it
actually
there's not always a lot to talk about
with with with school shootings so
they're just so tragic but this one had
some interesting policy
um
implications want to get your thoughts
on i think most people are familiar with
the fact patterns um and the the main
issue right now
is that the parents have been charged
yes uh and that's unusual
and they've been charged with murder or
like involuntary manslaughter and not
like
child abuse or neglect or some of the
other things that that's usually the
precedent and something like this sorry
god yeah so um believe it or not i went
to law school a million years ago um and
so my understanding of the the way
they're getting charged is under kind of
the old-school criminal law
um so there are different standards of
behavior um so there's
you know normal behavior and then
there's what's called negligence
and then there's
a higher level of negligence what you'd
call criminal negligence
which then can spill into recklessness
uh and then after recklessness is some
kind of
um
uh
motivated criminal behavior so typically
recklessness uh is a pretty high
standard
um and so what they're they're doing is
they're arguing that in this case
the parents behavior was so bad
that you can hold them to be criminally
liable
um
based upon
what they did
um which is in this case buying a
firearm for their 15 year old son
um and then ignoring various admonitions
and warning signs and um meeting with
the
school administration and some other
things
um it's a very very aggressive
legal attack in my opinion
um and
uh i
find myself torn genuinely on it in the
sense that um the the fact that the
prosecutors are trying to go in this
direction
um i think
is is something that is interesting
um
and i'm not saying that they're gonna
win
but i think it's interesting that they
bring it because if you're
a parent in other parts of the country
like oh [ __ ] like you actually get in
trouble for that
um
and regardless of whether or not it ends
up being a winning case for the
prosecutors and i think that's part of
this i think what they're doing is
they're trying to bring this case
in order to send a message
um that there is a line that you
shouldn't cross
um
uh around and i don't think anyone would
argue that they intended this but that
that this was criminally reckless
yeah um
and and then you look at this fact
pattern you think okay like is there a
fact pattern where you think that
parents maybe should be responsible
and i think most of us can imagine a
scenario where you're like okay that was
like just you know way beyond like if
like your
child came to you and was like hey like
you know i'm i'm like
you know having these these terrible
terrible harmful thoughts then you bring
out we're like hey here's a gun you know
like you'd you know and then
um
like like there's there's a threshold at
which you might want to
actually have some kind of
responsibility
um right
so i i find myself
um torn but kind of interested
and sort of
impressed frankly by the prosecutors
taking this attack
um now i am not sure that the parents
either will be or should be held guilty
but i think that even if they aren't
guilty under the law it actually does
send a message that's like look there's
a threshold at which we're going to
start trying to hold people responsible
right and look i always hesitate to like
jump to conclusions when these trial
these these cases are it's just getting
tried in the media right now um like we
talked about kyle rittenhouse and other
things like there are things that we
don't know everything but what appears
to have happened was that yeah the
parents bought their 15 year old a gun
and then he was caught in school both
looking at bullets and then the day of
shooting drawing like horrific school
shooting pictures and then the parents
who came in that day and met with a
counselor
allegedly
uh
didn't mention to the counselor or
anyone that their kid just got a gun um
and they also didn't take it they also
didn't take him home
yeah they left him there
um
i guess like this this standard of um
when your kids [ __ ] up how much trouble
do parents get in right and it feels
like a gray it's important area to find
but it's gray right um
if uh and i think guns you could
probably just define as different but if
your kid takes your car and
kills somebody with it um or take your
knife or take the chainsaw or you know
that that sort of thing and you were
i don't know there was something
generally speaking i think most everyone
agrees that it would be too much to hold
parents responsible for the actions of
their children right i think
this situation is something where
um it begins to blur that line because
you know the parents bought him a gun um
and
uh anything else you just named it
doesn't make any sense it's like hey i
have knives in the house who cares hey
like there's a car in the house who
cares like you know it's like hey
like you know uh but in this case it's
like look i bought the kid a gun and if
if you buy the kid a gun
there is some sense that you at least
don't think the kids are danger like if
you know so
um
i i don't think parents should be held
responsible for their their children do
um it parents should be held responsible
for what they themselves do uh you know
and and there's only a very select
number of situations where what the
parents do
um actually
uh can lead you to to feel like okay
they actually had some part in it i do
like it's one of these things like okay
we have proven time and time again that
we're in
enable unable i'm not sure
unwilling if it's a skill or a will
problem but we just can't regulate guns
in the united states of america um
but it did feel like me there is a um
maybe a shortcut is just regulate some
of the stuff in public opinion um which
maybe is to kind of your point earlier
where this is like uh
like
like a
social pressure that if you are if your
kids are having guns or people your
family having guns that there is
responsible gun ownership um
at least that's expected of you or
massive massive consequences if you
don't um
i don't know but it look it's tragic my
heart goes out to that entire community
um
yeah it's it's awful
but and you know and and it is the case
too that
you know like thousands of parents are
buying their kids guns and you know
nothing like this happens i mean
yeah
i mean that's that's happening around
the country all the time um
but it's a killing machine you know if
you're like regardless where you stand
on gun rights like if people are gonna
have them they better learn how to use
them safely holy crap well this is one
of the tragic things too that you know i
wrote in
my book that there are 300 million farms
in this country your point about not
being able to regulate them i mean this
country is the most heavily armed place
in the history of the world
my parents in florida like have a gun
for safety reasons it's like
there's no real instruction manual when
you get one you know what i'm saying
it's not like
i don't talk about like no one i mean
they don't even have to they don't
really show you how to use it either
unless you ask um
generally speaking now there's some
responsible gun shops and i'm not an
expert here not pretending to be but um
it does seem pretty easy to get and give
out man that's terrifying well it's one
of the ingredients why we're going to
see over the next number of uh
days in the u.s that disintegration is
so painful here it's like you know it's
like in another
society if there's like a mentally ill
15 year old kid with violent fantasies i
mean you know
he's not going to tell he is yeah yeah
he's not going to kill four people
so we'll see how that trial pays out i'm
going to preserve my own i guess
judgment to you we learn more the facts
it's not just from the prosecution the
media but oh awful um but i'm glad you
got your thoughts
chris cuomo was fired cnn
um
foreign i was surprised that he was
fired from from cnn i i tweeted out some
people beat me up over it but
um
yeah like i i mean he he did some things
that uh
you know uh were obviously
um
not good not good bad possible you know
i i feel like a lot of them you kind of
expected because you know it was his
brother and his brother was in a tough
spot so you know like you do you think
that
it was much more realistic i think to
expect him to do things on behalf of his
brother to be like oh can't journalists
you know the rest of it yes um and and
and you know and cnn had already kind of
um
you know started tiptoeing around this
stuff because they'd allowed
uh
chris to interview governor cuomo yeah
you know and and so if you already are
at that point um so i thought when he
was suspended that that would be it i
think that there's something else going
on where either there's like a
communication or some other piece of
information that
uh cnn's privy to that the rest of us
are not um because uh you know and there
are some people that thought he should
be fired based upon the stuff that was
already out
but i i think there's something else
yeah i don't really get mad about this
type of stuff because look and you and i
and carly's been on here too we've
railed against the media we have plenty
we know the i think we know the media
pretty well but i'm never actually mad
at their actions like on a human level
because
they're not pretending they're not
biased you know i'm saying like they're
for-profit entities they're not claiming
i mean they
they maybe exude the fact that they're
true news but their
their bias is so obvious and their spin
is so obvious and you know i think i
think that's kind of uh par for the
course at this point and for this in
this case your point
his bias was extremely obvious like
everybody knew it was his brother
to see an end to be like oh let me get
the objective take on the governor cuomo
situation of course not but i i also
will say that like i think i'm a bit
biased on this one because uh chris
cuomo was one of the
better journalists to me on the
presidential where he seemed to actually
take in what i was saying with an open
mind yeah
treated us with respect
uh pretty early on um in a way that was
relatively
memorable for me as a candidate i was
like oh [ __ ] like you know like chris
gets it
um and so i i it could be that my
reaction is um is influenced by that
yeah well i mean i just the firing is
surprising because like this is what
they do they do influence now
i think there's something else going on
too yeah
you know another thing too that i'll say
it's like i worked at cnn for a little
bit cnn does not seem to care about like
quote unquote pressure or like op-eds
like like cnn genuinely just seems to
do what it thinks it is best
um
you know like jeff zucker i mean runs
the place he has his own so there's
something up um that i don't think that
we're seeing and they did allude to that
right they did say like they did wrong
yeah i think yes i think that's not um
so that's rough um
yeah maybe they're letting them say face
or something because the last thing
anybody needs inc not just cnn all of us
we don't need a second cuomo
scandal um and this wasn't really
scandal this was a bit of one but like
you know
we all kind of saw it it was kind of
public that more
more inside the coemo investigations put
it that way i don't think we all are
jonesing for that you know
[Music]
people who've been really up on my stuff
know that i met elizabeth holmes at the
white house actually if you watch the
elizabeth holmes documentary on hbo
which is a really good watch um bad
blood
yes bad blood um if you watch closely
you'll see i pop up i pop up in her
white house photos where
when she's at the white house it's like
you know there's yang just standing
there
um and so i met her
and i'm not sure if my meeting her
uh
pushes me in a particular direction
i feel like she defrauded people
[Laughter]
like i you know and i think now they're
they're trying she's uh presenting it as
as if her um
or like ex-boyfriend was like the
masterminds van gaali type it's like
maybe um
but
you know i like i i feel like she
defrauded people personally
yo you tweeted you tweeted in april of
2019 i just googled andrew yang
elizabeth holmes found that picture uh
but then you said god asked yesterday
what i thought when i met elizabeth
holmes in the white house it wasn't a
long conversation my main memory was
that she had a deep voice
[Laughter]
she so i don't know if you know that but
you know she yeah she changed her voice
yeah yeah she so just talking to her she
was like hi and like and i'm just like
huh it seemed like an affectation but i
was like
you know what what do i know um so
this is one thing i will say
oh man i i'll say it because i thought
it whatever um so
i have met
dozens hundreds
of impressive entrepreneurs over my
career impressive people uh yeah and
there's a you have to
um and there's like a certain energy
that a lot of them emanate particularly
entrepreneurs
um and uh you know
meeting elizabeth holmes
i did not come away with that feeling i
did not come away with that feeling of
like oh
like this per like i can see how this
person founded a billion dollar company
blah blah blah it's like you know like
there's like a certain
um presence or aura or like you know
energy like i didn't get that
from her now
uh and that that's a recollection i
remember like contemporaneously like it
that wasn't me like going back and you
still remember that yeah yeah yeah like
i remember it's like i remember meeting
her and being more like the the word i
would use for myself was confused
like i met her and i came away confused
i was like
i don't know what to make of that that
person or this conversation or like it
wasn't
um it wasn't clear to me at all
um and so then later when this
information comes out i was like oh you
know
that's not good that's so fascinating
though because
um she's known for charming
everyone the being so impressive like
henry kissinger and go down the walton's
like all these
in many ways american institutions are
like
infatuated with with her and her pitch
um
my question for you on this is
uh i want to talk about like
most entrepreneurs massaging the truth
you know um
and i don't mean that lying like i think
it's all like if you're like like that's
fraud right if you're like i don't mean
the defrauding investor and uh
doing things that are you're at
deceiving investors is what i'm looking
for um but what i mean is like
you know when you're when you're
starting you're trying to get that first
investment or you're bootstrapping that
sort of thing you're not telling them
you're not showing all your warts you
know what i'm saying like you're not um
you're going to paint a great picture of
what you are going to build that's going
to be aspirational very naturally in
doing this um
have you ever like lived the
you know the at least from your end and
people pitching you because i know
you've done a lot of those like people
like not telling you the whole truth or
where where's that line because i do
think it's more gray i was the thought
line is like fraud right but it's in
between there can get kind of gray in
the startup world
it it can get great in the startup world
but that there no [ __ ] was fraud man i
mean
right now
[Laughter]
i've listened to the podcast a bit some
of these like bad blood parties talking
about the home show and she's like
she she does make some blatant lies and
they like slapped a pfizer logo on like
a you know they forged like a document
that got 100 million dollars like they
they lied a lot of [ __ ] but there's a
lot of stuff that'll like have truths
and and she was very very smart how she
chose her words a lot of time like for
example
they
um
you know there was a lot of upside with
their noses ability to be in the
battlefield like so if you're a soldier
you can uh
you know you directly test your blood in
the helicopter and you could start
transfusion on the fly like saving
thousands of lives and she has this
incredible story
about how this could work
um
she never says
that they actually developed this
product and that it works and that's
because like they didn't actually have a
defense contract they had nothing so but
the turns of phrase you were using that
were like
actually not fraudulent when you see
them in writing but it's fraudulent the
feel you know i don't know if you ever
felt that sorry i interrupted you but um
oh not at all i mean so so there's like
some stuff where
um you know you hype it up um yeah and
as long as you don't lie like that that
stuff's kind of par for the course yeah
um
and you know what they're noticing that
there's a lot of lying going on as you
said
uh
the i mean the hype stuff here is like
sure you know i mean that that that
stuff you do see a lot of if you're a
discerning investor type though i mean
you just cut through it you'd be like
hey so you have a defense contract
yeah
well it's like
i don't know like like in dating though
right uh when you first meet somebody
and you know
both of you like you're you're both like
the person you want to be you know and
then over time you figure out
you know everybody learns who you
actually are
to your point zach i feel for
entrepreneurs because
uh you know you do have to really sell
the dream
and then sometimes when it goes to [ __ ]
people are like oh screw you i hate you
and then you're like you know some of
those people sorry like um i i you know
i mean one example of this is like i
read the book and interviewed the
authors of the book on adam neumann and
we work oh yeah um
and that that stuff i think it's newman
actually but um
you know and and you look at him people
pillory that guy but then part of it is
they're like well
you know i mean he built like a big
company out of nothing and you know
there was initially something there and
the rest of it so like that there
like and in that case there was like a
lot of culpability in the system where a
lot of people were like well you know
we'll make money we'll just like
freaking ride this train um uh so
yes
yeah so there there's like a mixed bag i
mean were there a lot of people that
really wanted to believe the idea of
like the the brilliant
uh woman founder of this
blood testing company and that it would
be this incredible story it's like yeah
there were some
biases that i think she used in her
favor
it was funny it's like in the way she
like subverted the sexism
um
yeah because you know i i mean i think
it's it's very very difficult for
um
women entrepreneurs uh you know and to
get some of the credibility
um
at certain stages um and then she
managed to do it all it's you know of
course in her case you know it was uh it
wasn't real
um which makes in in some ways all the
more painful because
she was on the cover of fortune magazine
she was
at the white house and uh like i'll
we'll close with this too it's like i
was at the white house you know
presidential ambassador of global
entrepreneurship
i do think that there was a little bit
of cherry picking of uh the people who
were in that group based upon our
identities like i i joked at the time
that i was like hey i'm like the token
asian i probably was a token asian you
know
like
like i might not
not be joking that much um and and
elizabeth holmes i think was there in
large part because she was a young woman
um and you know and then they kind of
built a picture they built a photo
i think that it's one of the
frustrations
um
of some people and some people it's like
does representation matter yes it does
um like should we be
like you know just trying to
cram reality into photo ops so that's
like oh we got to have one of each and
then there's and if it's not there then
they're like they no it's like you know
you you there needs to be some substance
that
uh is real
and that if you pursue the appearance
in the face of reality
um sometimes you end up with very very
bad things like much worse than the
frankly like the egg on your face of
having
uh you know a fraudster like as part of
a white house photo i mean who cares
about that really though you know on one
level you could be like okay that's not
good but like but at the very very
extreme you wind up trying to sell
people a reality that does that that
that could and i'm going to say
something very difficult as a captain of
this conversation like
if we're unable to have
difficult conversations about
kamala harris's electability because
people are afraid to say something um
because she's
like the first woman of color vp oh by
the way our entire democracy may hinge
on our ability to have an honest
conversation about whether she's like
the right choice you know like someone
needs to step up and
have the hard convos
um because the country's destiny relies
on it
that's a very good way to put it man
it's um
i don't i think people are getting
afraid of getting being cast as a racist
being cast as an [ __ ] i don't know
just like twitter backlash i don't you
know i don't i don't well it's one
reason why i just go with the empiricals
like look polls five points worse than
joe i mean you can't argue with that
it's just a number but you know like
that but but ignoring that is uh
is is
potentially disastrous
yeah yeah i mean look
trump
is the definition of authentic at least
to himself i know he's a liar and
there's another thing but like he
the people who support him feel like he
is honest with him he's established an
authentic connection with his supporters
this
one of the things como's been hit on her
entire career is that lack of
authenticity and it's a lot of democrats
are bad at this um so that's the big
challenge we have that is a problem and
democrats don't talk like human beings
talk you know it's like democrats talk
like politicians talk and the [ __ ] is
just not working
anymore
um and so like you know
we we need to grow up you know or else
we're gonna wind up with
uh autocrat trump 2024
uh and
and if that happened this is going to be
you know it's like democrats lost to
this guy once in 16
almost lost him again in in 2020 i mean
you know victory's a victory so you know
got a clown in the back um but can't
can't lose to him twice can't shouldn't
have lost him once can't lose to him
twice this is the moment where i'm like
alright we should stop talking and do
something so i'm like all right andrew
maybe you should run again but
i don't know if like i i mean i
obviously think you're the world of a
better candidate and better human being
than this guy but i don't know if you'd
be able to beat him um
i don't know what you thought you're
saying like if i well i i think if i
were the democratic candidate and the
establishment machine got behind me i
think i'd beat him because the democrats
would be like sure into it and then i
think i'd get a bunch of like the
um
folks
but but i i think
trying to entertain that possibility is
you know
you know like i'm
saying that the establishment somehow
like got got behind me
um which
you know i think we've all seen like you
know he's not
it's not exactly their first impulse
um so
so you know so i so i'm not necessarily
saying like hey you know like choose
yang
um i'm saying choose someone who can
beat trump if you get behind him and so
look it's four or five states man that's
that's what you have to focus on who
pulls better there you know that's true
and those numbers came out last weekend
oh by the way right now it's donald
trump so yeah that's good
yeah that's not good they always show
these national polls and those are
worthless you have to look at the
michigan ohio wisconsin pennsylvania and
now i guess like georgia arizona and a
few others but um yep those are the
states let's do it let's preserve
civilization
fair representation act that's what's
called yeah fair representation act
board party nonpartisan primaries ranked
choice voting third party trying to
activate the people
um you know one thing i i will say
um to
we are
collecting five dollar donations to the
ford party
through the end of december
uh so if you are into the forward party
just donate five ten bucks it's not
about the money it's just about raising
your hand and saying that we need a
different approach to politics um anyone
who donates to that you're gonna be
helping us a lot because what i'm going
to do is i'm going to take all of these
individual donors that we have and then
go to
uh deep pocketed folks and say hey look
the people want this so if the people
want it then i'm going to be able to to
take that case there you go
forwardparty.com
yep forwardparty.com let's fix it
all right guys we'll be back next week
later
[Music]
you